another economic statement lots of money
to be spent and the Treasury wants to
think of this as the second act of a
kind of three act saga and let's just
talk you through where we've come so far
so act one was what we saw in the spring
I'm going to show you this kind of tower
of money that was spent in the spring
employment support that's the furloughs
getting business support for different
companies around the country household
support so welfare and then you've got
public services as well now add all of
that stuff up now that's the stuff who
has already spent back in March and
you're talking about 160 billion pounds
and now we have this extra money so the
stimulus Act - it's about 30 billion
pounds up to 30 billion pounds according
to the Chancellor take all of that in
total you're talking about 190 billion
pounds it's even more than that when
you're talking about overall borrowing
but look that might look small but 30
billion pounds any other budget would be
considered enormous in terms of extra
spending so it's worth just taking that
and stripping out where that money is
actually going to go - so different
measures across the economy and what I
can do is split it up between different
parts of the economy so jobs hospitality
housing and the furloughs scheme those
different segments taking us up and then
ladder the staircase of 30 billion
pounds and let's just go through some of
those schemes so you've got kickstart
scheme apprentices extra money for jobs
you've got hospitality so the v80
holiday that's about 4 billion pounds in
total there's a tiny sliver I've got
there that's they eat out to help out
scheme that voucher scheme actually very
small in terms of the actual spending on
it but very eye-catching
indeed you've got infrastructure green
homes Prime Minister talked a lot about
that about 9 billion pounds and then
that dark a bit of that Tower there
that's the stamp duty hold a about 4
billion pounds that is going to be a
real difference if you were planning to
buy a home or indeed to sell it in the
coming six months and then the furlough
scheme now this job retention bonus
might well cost up to nine point four
billion pounds but that all depends on
basically everyone who's followed at the
moment coming back into work in practice
it could be a lot smaller but that would
mean higher unemployment and the
Treasury says that when you look across
the whole of the economy and split up
different parts of the population by how
much they earn Ashley it is the bottom
10 percent who are the only segments
nearly decile who are seeing an increase
as a result of all of what we're going
through at the moment including their
ends event
whereas it is the top 10% who see the
biggest impact on their incomes all said
though you are talking about a lot of
people losing out that I'm afraid is the
impact of what happens when you have a
recession